so what we want to do is try and piece
together we've got like all these
different values of theta all these
different angles that we can put into
sine what's it going to look like now
you already know some of these values
right some of them are really easy to
work out sine 0 sine 0 degrees what's
the y-coordinate here you'd know this
from last time it's still 0 so if I have
this as the theta axis and this is the
sine theta axis when theta is 0 when the
angle is 0 sine theta is also 0 okay I'm
gonna go across yeah that'll be now
let's go to the angle we're at right now
45 degrees if I make these markers every
90 then 45 will be somewhere in the
middle okay
it's 0.707 so let's put a scale up here
I'm gonna make a marker one I'm gonna
ask you in about 45 seconds why I chose
one and zero point seven is like 3/4 the
way up roughly so something like this
maybe there you go okay
that's at 45 degrees so sine of 45
degrees is that zero point seven oh
seven number dot dot dot what's sine of
90 have a look where's now you've got
your big unit circle you're nice woman
you drew yesterday right 90 degrees
takes you up on two you've rotated up
and you're here right so what's the
y-coordinate up there it's 1 so sine of
90 degrees should be up here at 1 okay
now I said I was going to ask why have I
made one the top it's the unit circle
that's as high as you can possibly go
there's nowhere up here you can't get to
1.5 or 2 or 3 so 1 is the highest you
can go and you can see that because as
we keep going you guys told me that sine
135 is the same number you come back
so 130 fires here it's like that it's
coming down strange when we looked at
parabolas they just kind of went up and
up and up cubics went up and up and up
this guy is sort of looping back okay
I'm gonna pause for a minute you guys
have number one your unit circle number
two you've got a calculator I want you
to finish this and put some more points
on there what kind of a shape are you
created I will give you about three or
four minutes to try and put together a
shape and if you think you've got
something call me over I've been I've
looked around what a few of you started
to draw some of you are on the right
track some of you are confused which is
fine because this is confusing so let me
help you out okay
shaming how am I getting these points
what I'm doing is I'm using my
calculator I'm using the unit circle I
try out an angle like say for example
270 degrees and each time the question
I'm asking is what is sine of that angle
sine of 270 if I come back over here 270
Gries on the unit circle you start on
the positive x-axis and you go around 90
degrees 180 degrees 270 lands me down
here so here's this spot where my finger
is what is the y-coordinate just the
y-coordinate because that's what sine is
after all what's the y-coordinate of
where my finger is it's negative one
which is why I'm down here do you see
that negative one and I keep on putting
values in and I keep on getting points
now what I notice is I get to 360 and I
could keep going but do you remember
when you told me oh if you get something
at 45 the same thing happens 360 degrees
later and the same thing happens 360
degrees later after that this shape from
zero is going to start repeating at 360
it's gonna go back up like this and then
it's gonna do this weird thing I guess
my graph would go to what's the next one
five
40 now what is this you've never seen a
shape like this before which is why
we're investing time into it if you do
your best to join the dots and I'd love
you to have a go at this now with a
pencil if you can this is the shape that
you will create okay now this guy here
right this guy here is strange it waves
around up and down it oscillates is
another way of describing it okay now we
have a winner fancy name for this kind
of shape that exists not just in maths
but also in maths we call this guy a
sinusoidal wave now it's a weird long
phrase which is why mathematicians never
say it that's why we only ever say sine
okay it's a sine wave or sine curve okay
now by the way creep piece of trivia
whether or not you've heard of the word
or not um you guys all know what a sinus
is because you all have one actually
have several the main one that people
think of is the thing inside their nasal
cavity it's this curved section inside
your nose okay and that's why you have a
sinus okay so sine
sign is short for sinusoidal whip okay
[Laughter]
okay let me help you we're going to do
this one a bit quicker because we're
familiar with this shape now we did sign
feet up this Wilson is it this is the
graph of sine theta okay now I want us
to think about cause and I promise it
will be quicker okay now it is very
closely related but watch I'm gonna put
down some basic points and then I'm
gonna join them all up okay and you're
gonna help me let's start at the
beginning we start at the origin right
when theater zero that's here what's cos
of 0 what's the x coordinate of this
spot look carefully what is the
x-coordinate of this spot it's 1 so when
theta is 0 when I'm on this axis I'm at
1 when I keep going along when I think
about 90 degrees look at where you are
on the unit circle you go all the way up
to here
what is the x-coordinate up there it's
zero ninety degrees zero and a hundred
and eighty degrees I come back round and
it's negative one very good now you're
starting to get a pattern here aren't
you it's gonna come back up to zero it's
going to go to one and it's just going
to keep on doing its dance ok now if you
fill in some in between points like I
did up here you will find a very
familiar shape emerging it's gonna look
like this
[Music]
okay now have a look closely
Shh what I want you to do is notice
because I've got these right next to
each other right put your pens down and
look up for a minute I'm going to pinch
this because it's closed
look closely eyes on the board I want
you to look at the sine wave I want you
to look at the sine wave and I want you
to watch carefully as I cover up a very
specific section of it see here from
naught to 90 see this little spot here
I'm just gonna cover it up now when I do
that have a look at the sine wave now
doesn't doesn't that look familiar it's
the same graph but but what part did I
cover up again what part I covered up
the first now here is 90 degrees
what does cosine have to do with 90
degrees it's the compliment it's the
complement this graph is the complement
of this graph it's off by 90 degrees
right so thank you very much okay
so this guy here can you add in some
values for me okay this is the side
curve this is the cosine curve okay
now I'll come to him and sit it but in a
second but in super weird super super
weird okay can I just point something
out before we leave off these graphs
okay both of these graphs I stopped but
only because I ran out of space there's
no reason to think that it will stop
doing the thing that it's doing up and
down and up and down right so what I'm
going to do is I'm just gonna chuck an
arrow on the end of that graph and the
same with this it's never ending but
it's never ending in a particular way
right the parabola is also never ending
the straight line is also never ending
but the sine and the cosine curves they
never end but they repeat over and over
again right in fact if I covered you
know how I covered up 90 degrees if I
covered up 360 degrees
you just get exactly the same shape
going up and down up and down so we have
a name for this when something repeats
over and over again we call it periodic
now the periodic table is named after
this same idea because you know how
there's the rows in the periodic table
right each row the reason why you go on
to a new row is because by the time you
get to a new row the new particle the
new what's the word I'm looking for the
new element that you've got has got
similar kinds of properties to the
element directly above it you guys you
guys know this right you've studied the
periodic table so it's the same idea
that you get the same behavior over and
over again these are called periodic
functions okay they repeat forever okay